let's think about this you know nothing
about f of X this is pretty much
everything that's giving you the
question apart from a few extra words
that just kind of had the equations okay
they tell you that definite integral
above and then they say can you evaluate
this definite integral below that's all
they give you okay now see is you don't
know anything about the function this
tells you this is not about calculus
right you can't differential you got
integrated there's no wait you can
access what's going on if we need to dig
back a little further I think well it's
a definite integral what else does a
definite what how else can I work out
definite integral if not by calculus and
the answer is x 50 about carrier right
so this is just like this is just like
being a question like this is a very
potter 1025 of this guy okay now because
you see lots of these ones before you
kind of get the Q you like ah I as an
extension what student I cannot
integrate this so therefore it has to be
something else okay it's a it's not even
a semicircle actually it's a it's a
quadrant right as a quadrant of a circle
so it's only on the right hand side si
si okay pi r squared would be 25 pi
about actually only what a quarter of
the circle so 25 pilot forum right so
you think about that through the lens of
area rather than actually hasn't been
doing calculus okay actually solving
that question now when you have a look
at this guy I go to purchase it just the
same way now to get a picture of what's
going on this will really help be I
wouldn't draw something that looks like
this okay now remember I don't know what
f of X is so I'm going to draw some
random curve right and I'm just going to
say that the area from here to here
underneath the curve is this so what
might this looks like look like well
let's draw something like this in any
other follow along would be if i go from
0 to 40 24 right and i manufacture some
kind of color
lifeless let's do something I can
replicate okay okay oh that's right so
some really looking graph like that okay
and apparently this area underneath here
this area is even too ok so now I need
to think about how does this thing this
is f of X room how does this relate to
this guy right there are two things
happening right the first thing I notice
is it says f of X minus three so I just
figure out its tune forbidden okay what
that tells me is there is a horizontal
shift its shifted three units to the
right and that means you you look at the
boundaries haha what a coincidence right
these batteries has have also shifted
three do this to that right so what this
curve looks like if I forgot about the
two right if I just covered this right
now these are the sieve area do you see
that it's just that I've moved this
whole shape over this way okay so that's
what it would be without the two what
does that mean well I've not only moved
to the right but I've also moved oh ok
so now now let's get a secondary picture
going on ok if I draw a lot where I got
zero to four anymore I'm now worried
about 37 ok so they go uh I guess 327
something like that ok I had this shape
before but now I'm going to take that
save a shape which has been moved over
to be 37 and it's going to move up ok so
to you that's so this scale is getting
pretty terrible but let's call that too
right so now that shape over there is
going to sit oh my god two units higher
than this one right so it's going to be
this shame you know this we don't
looking out of it what did wanna drop
see it like that so there this like I
said the scale is pretty terrible uh
this is my six that I had before
it I think you say well what's the
missing part and the answer is it's a
rectangle that's sitting just below the
area that I actually already know and
its dimensions are four by two is eight
confirming that this is the worst scale
of all time okay so therefore this area
is going to be the original one plus the
red table it's 40 okay so what did I do
that they were you to do number one I
thought I can't use calculus so
therefore this question wasn't bit to do
with calculus right this is a this is a
great concentric question because it
helps to see help success do you
remember no turn it away integral
they've got area first about area first
and then we were amazed that actually 80
differentiation would actually give us
this sub would evaluate these functions
for us okay and then secondly what I was
assessing was so there's actually some
accrual for what bar can you work out
okay how does this then shift up into
this a change